-President Trump
spent the weekend
attacking the Democrats
running for president
and the Democrats investigating
him in Congress.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
For the first two years
of his presidency,
Trump enjoyed unified Republican
power in Washington.
But after the blue wave election
in November,
Trump is besieged by Democrats
on all sides,
from the Democrats
investigating him in Congress
to the Democrats
running for president.
In fact, tonight,
after we taped this,
Trump held a rally
in El Paso, Texas,
to argue for his border wall.
Now, normally,
when Trump holds these rallies,
he gets the full undivided
attention of the media
and the political world.
But tonight he had to deal with
a rival rally
held by a popular Democrat
in a march organized by
local activists.
-Dueling rallies at the Mexico
border tonight in El Paso.
President Trump and rising
Democratic star Beto O'Rourke
both in the West Texas city
tonight.
O'Rourke plans to lead
a one-mile march celebrating
the culture, history,
and diversity of the region.
His speech afterward
timed to coincide with
the President's rally
at the El Paso County Coliseum.
-Amazing. Not only are
they holding a rally
at the same time, but they're
also holding a march.
There's no better way to troll
Trump than with exercise.
[ Laughter ]
What's Trump gonna do?
Chase after the marchers
in his golf cart?
"Slow down. This thing is
running low on batteries."
Meanwhile, over the weekend,
two more Democrats announced
their presidential campaigns,
adding to what is
an already historic number
of women in the field.
On Sunday, Minnesota Senator
Amy Klobuchar
announced her campaign,
and she did it the most
Minnesota way possible --
covered in snow.
-Now, we don't let a little snow
stop us.
We don't let a little cold
Like, are you guys even cold?
So let's join together, as one
nation, indivisible, under God,
and pursue the good.
-I promise I will vote for you
if you go inside!
[ Laughter ]
Look at all that snow.
Who's gonna be your
running mate?
Marge Gunderson?
[ Laughter ]
Is she in Minnesota
or north of the wall?
And, of course,
after her announcement,
Trump couldn't help but take
a shot at Klobuchar on Twitter.
And in doing so, he once again
revealed that he doesn't know
the difference between weather
and climate change.
-President Trump not impressed,
tweeting,
"Well, it happened again.
Amy Klobuchar announced that she
is running for president,
talking proudly of fighting
global warming
while standing in
a virtual blizzard of
snow, ice,
and freezing temperatures.
Bad timing.
By the end of her speech, she
looked like a snowman or woman."
-Why do we have to
keep explaining to
the President of
the United States
that weather and climate
are two different things?
We live in a country where
science teachers
have to tell their students,
"I don't care
what the President said."
Not to mention history teachers,
English teachers
and P.E. teachers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I don't care what he said,
Timmy.
Sit-ups are not fake news."
[ Laughter ]
Shouldn't have to live
like this.
It's like if a kid pees
his pants when he's 3,
it's understandable.
But if he does it when he's 30,
you put him in an Uber.
To explain this one more time,
just because it snows once
doesn't negate
long-term climate trends
caused by the burning of
fossil fuels.
It's kind of like this.
When your hair looks normal once
in a while, that's weather.
But most of the time it looks
like this, and that's climate.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Klobuchar's announcement
came just a day after
Massachusetts Senator
Elizabeth Warren
officially threw her hat
in the ring, as well.
And rather than focus
exclusively on Trump,
Warren argued that Trump is just
the product of a broken system.
-The man in the White House is
not the cause of what is broken.
He is just the latest
and most extreme symptom
of what's gone wrong in America.
-Basically what she is saying is
Trump himself isn't the disease.
He's just the symptom.
Actually, he's
a bunch of symptoms.
He's basically everything
you'd see
on the back of a pill bottle.
May cause inflammation,
excessive sweating, hair loss,
discoloration of the skin,
and dryness of the mouth.
-10,000 known
or suspes-- gang members.
Every single car out there,
even the really expenses ones,
God bless the United Shtates.
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh, is it time for my speech?
Quick. Give me a glass of sand."
[ Laughter ]
Now, Warren isn't alone
among Democrats
in wanting to focus on policy
and on the specific ways
in which the system
has failed working people.
The entire Democratic Party's
messaging in the midterms
was focused on issues
like healthcare
and voter suppression,
and it produced the largest
margin of victory
in midterms history,
so naturally Trump has responded
to that message
with his only move -- racism.
-2020 is also clearly
on President Trump's mind.
Saturday, he lashed out at
Senator Warren on Twitter,
alluding to her past claims
of Native American status,
for which she has apologized.
The President appeared
to make a joking reference
to the tragic Trail of Tears
relocation and genocide
of Native Americans.
-"Today, Elizabeth Warren,
sometimes referred to by me
as Pocahontas,
joined the race for president.
Will she run as our first Native
American presidential candidate,
or has she decided that
after 32 years,
this is not playing
so well anymore?
See you on the campaign trail,
Liz."
-Now, this tweet
was obviously racist,
and yet there are actually
some conservatives arguing
that it wasn't a reference to
the Trail of Tears
because Trump doesn't know
what that is.
Fox News political analyst
Brit Hume
responded to claims that Trump's
tweet was racist
by saying yes, because Trump is
noted for his knowledge of
19th century American history,
vis-a-vis the native population.
They're actually defending Trump
by saying he's too dumb
to be racist.
First of all, if you ever find
yourself asking
is Trump dumb or is he racist,
the answer is most likely C --
all of the above.
Second, Trump has said publicly
that he's a big fan
of Andrew Jackson,
who carried out the forced
removal and ethnic cleansing
of Native Americans.
In fact, early in his
presidency, Trump even claimed
Jackson foresaw the Civil War
decades before it happened,
although Trump didn't really
seem to have
a strong understanding of what
the Civil War actually was.
-They said my campaign is most
like my campaign and win,
was most like Andrew Jackson.
I mean, had Andrew Jackson
been a little bit later,
you wouldn't have had
the Civil War.
He was really angry
that he saw what was happening
with regard to the Civil War.
He said,
"There's no reason for this."
People don't realize, you know,
the Civil War, um --
-Yeah.
-You think about it, why?
People don't ask that question.
But why was there the Civil War?
Why could that one
not have been worked out?
-What do you mean
why was there the Civil War?
[ Laughter ]
Everyone knows why.
It's not like the first line of
Abraham Lincoln's
Emancipation Proclamation was,
"I don't know
why I'm doing this."
[ Laughter ]
Trump and his allies are
clearly rattled by the fact that
for the first time
they have to face real questions
from the Democrats
running for President
or investigating them
in Congress.
And there was no better example
of that
than Trump's acting attorney
general, Matt Whitaker,
who testified before the House
Judiciary Committee on Friday.
Democrats tried to get Whitaker
to answer basic questions
about his role
in the Russian investigation.
And for the first time in any
congressional hearing in memory,
the witness told them
that they were out of time.
-In your capacity as
acting attorney general,
have you ever been asked
to approve any request or action
to be taken by
the special counsel?
-Mr. Chairman, I see that your
five minutes is up, and so...
-I'm sorry, but you don't get
to do that, dude.
That's like Tom Brady
chucking a flag
and calling pass interference.
The way it works is Tom Brady
winks at a ref
and the ref throws the flag.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is what happens.
This is what happens
when Trump and his allies
finally have to answer real
questions for the first time
from people that aren't just
there to protect them.
Trump is dealing with several
serious challenges
to his presidency and real
oversight from Congress.
And by the time
this is all over,
Trump may no longer be
the president of --
-The United Shtates.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]